okay we're gonna giving a look at what
could be the future of smartphones with
two brand-new foldable phones Samsung
unveiled its highly anticipated Galaxy Z
flip yesterday the phone's bendable
glass screen is the first of its kind
this comes a week after Motorola
released its new razor the razor is an
updated version of the flip phone that
was a huge success more than 15 years
ago some of us remember those yeah Dan
Ackerman senior managing editor with our
partners had seen that as he here with a
first look at the new Samsung Galaxy XIV
lip flip before it hit stores this
Friday good morning Dan hey guys and
you're gonna give me that at the end of
this thing this is so cool yeah it's
really give us a little demonstration
interesting now it looks like a regular
phone when you hold it up yeah but then
you go like this and look at that the
screen bends and unlike some of the
earlier flexible phones and there have
been a couple the screen is actually
made of a type of flexible glass not
plastic
yeah and that could potentially make it
more durable and it closes completely
closes completely and then you have
something that fits in a human size
pocket which is something that people
complain about a lot of the big screen
phones takes pictures now when even when
it's closed when it's closed this is
kind of fun there's a tiny little
display down here so if I hit this
button twice I get a little tiny camera
lens right guys right there you gotta
turn it over and then if I open it up
when we go into the camera right that's
[Laughter]
even when it's closed you can see the
time right and you can see the time you
can see some notifications it's a full
screen on the front but it's a little
something and then if you have the
camera open it knows in some apps that
you have it folded like it moves the
controls at the bottom it's almost like
a little mini laptop like that some
might notice it prevents some my note
but dialing if a red spot dialing and it
keeps the screen frankly safe I'm
paranoid about phone screens when I see
a naked phone with the big screen out I
just get anxiety why is it so expensive
it's 1,400
it is but that's not considered
expensive for a premium phone anymore
this is the Samsung Galaxy S 20 ultra
there are other big new finally
announced yesterday and this is $13.99
and if you get a tricked out iPhone it
can be closer to fourteen or fifteen
hundred dollars it used to be $9.99 was
the most expensive phone and now that's
like the entry price for a premium so
you think this is gonna take off dan
because as you noted there have been
earlier versions of this that kind of
bombs and now I think we had to get
through a couple of generations of the
technology first to get something that
worked better and you see there's moving
parts on this and the hinge and
everything and the nice thing about
regular phones is there's almost no
moving parts in them so it's hard for
them to break down unless you drop it
and crack the screen so long-term
durability I think we're gonna have to
get something like this into a lot of
people's hands to really test and that's
and see how they can motor rollers razor
also has a bendable strana this is
actually the the Samsung S 20 ultra
which is their other big regular phone
okay but the razor has a bendable screen
it's made of plastic though and it's a
bit more of a retro play it looks like
the old razor that everybody runs to
have the flip there so why do you think
bendable phones are our back is it
psychologically people just want to be
looking at their phones anymore they
want the experience of a shutting it and
putting it away there's a small niche
group of people who really like flip
phones dental screens or not because
they get rid of a lot of the
distractions because you can't put a lot
of you know apps on the the retro-style
ones these are just regular Android
phones that mimic that mechanism but I
think that people are just burned out on
these big slab phones they all look the
same feel the same big thing of glass
and metal if you want someone to buy a
new phone every year or two years you
got to give them something new and
interesting and at least this is new an
interactive map probably years they'd
like to let a technology whether it's 5g
or big screens of facial recognition
mature first before they get into it and
then everyone goes oh I can't believe
it's on an iPhone now when everyone else
says but we've been doing this for two
years
Apple is working on this technology you
know they have some patents from
flexible screens and I would not be
surprised if at some point you see that
if you want to hang up on somebody
that's feel pretty good yes that is so
true and fewer but dials is also really
important we've had a couple of awkward
moments with that that's not good that's
not good thank you Dan Ackerman that's
another thing